hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
kennt das wenn ihr niesen müssen dann
geht es einfach nicht wir spielen heute
auf jeden fall wiederholt preston
debatten das heißt wir haben die
möglichkeit einen knopf zu drücken und
das ist ein etwas alter was ist das für
ein krasses beispiel direkt wir haben
einerseits unlimited money also wir
haben immer geld wäre was haben wollen
allerdings müssen wir jeden fall unser
familie töten
würdet ihr für unbegrenztes geld töten
das jetzt mal abgesehen ob die familie
ist oder nicht aber würde die irgend
jemand töten nur für unbegrenztes geld
ich habe den knopf ist nicht gedrückt
und 72 haben den knopf nicht gedrückt
also alles super übrigens immer wenn ich
in der minderheit will klatsche ich mir
eine einfach so you are able to become a
die fiction story kursniveau radio live
update wird also wir können uns
irgendeine person aussuchen aller zeiten
die wir sein wollen wir dürfen
allerdings nur ein halbes leben leben
würde ich auch nicht machen ich habe
nicht den knopf gedrückt und bin in der
minderheit und in der mehrheit also es
sind 50 prozent also ich würde sagen ich
mache meine halbe stelle also die
template or better than anyone with
jimmy page knopf labradors have your
guitars trepca berlin ein ace ist mir
das scheißegal ob ich will nicht gitarre
spielen mehrheit folgt nichts schert man
kann machen dass die zeit stehen bleibt
allerdings darf man am tag nur zehn
wörter sagen allein in diesen satz habe
ich schon locker zehn oder 40.000 viel
gesagt so wörter irgendwie schreibt man
die kommentare wie viel wird gerade in
diesen satz gesagt habe wird mir
interessieren wie viele verschiedene
ziffern jetzt in die kommentare getextet
verhärten ich meine dass die zeit stehen
bleibt ist schon ultra geil aber es
macht keinen sinn finde ich dass die
zeit stehen bleibt so ich meine
zwerghühner wenn ich die zeit zurück
spüren konnte dann würde ich mir noch
mal überlegen aber ich würde wieder
nicht den knopf drücken und bin mit
meiner antwort
warum bin ich in der minderheit you can
read write and speak and any language
that the ones to read this and what you
have to say that i would you
originalität wir haben wir dieser sache
hier einerseits die möglichkeit dass wir
reden schreiben und sprechen können in
jeder sprache allerdings bringt es uns
nix weil uns immer noch nur in unserer
grund sprache leute zuhören und sich das
durchlesen bzw
antworten das heißt es macht überhaupt
keinen sinn dass ich alles kann außer
dass ich anderen leuten zuhören kann
natürlich denkt man jetzt ja du kannst
natürlich alle sprachen und bla bla bla
bla bla kann mittlerweile deutsch
englisch perfekt französischen ganz
klein bisschen und im spanischen ganze
ein bisschen aber ich habe ja viel zu
viel ich würde nicht den knopf drücken
und ich finde in der minderheit
die leute denken einfach nicht nach ohne
spaß das hat einfach nur was mit logik
zu tun
das problem dabei ist halt so ein
bisschen überlegt euch mal der zeit wenn
ich derzeit irgendwie nach london fahren
würde könnte ich sagen okay herz des
kindes und blablabla das heißt auf
englisch sagen wenn ich allerdings da
den knopf gedrückt hätte könnte ich zwar
perfekt englisch und auch noch perfekt
spanisch und chinesisch und japanisch
und alles allerdings bringt es mir
nichts weil ich mich noch deutsch
verständigen kann
versteht ihr was ich meine amazing and
robotics es wird auf jeden fall drücken
oder spaß ich bin auch mit 81
in der über krasse mehrheit ich war
vielleicht drei jahren nicht mehr auf
tumblr you can see the future of
anything you what you can tell me what s
going to happen also wie können wir die
zukunft schauen und wissen was wann
passiert dürfte es aber niemand sagen
ist auch wieder nur eine logik sache
wenn ich nicht drücke kann ich nicht in
die zukunft schauen und kann es trotzdem
jeden sagen aber ich weiß es ja nicht
und wenn ich in die zukunft schauen kann
dann weiß ich es halt aber kann sagen
also natürlich drücke ich war kingsley
der mehrheit
ich bin locker heute schon von 15 sachen
bei 13 sachen in der mehrheit alter
meine wange tut gar nicht weh can have
any super power of your choice but i can
be used it personal gameserver schließen
das heißt wenn ich sagen würde okay ich
hab die superkraft dass ich alle
krankheiten heilen
dann kann ich nicht sagen okay ich bin
selber krank ich heile mich weil dann
will sterben
aber ich meine ja ich würd rücken
mehrheit des biopics representation of
the wurst 4 ohne spaß wer denkt sich
diese sachen aus das ist ultra krass ich
meine ich bin ein apple fan habe als
handy halt dieses iphone und ab meine
ganzen uni sachen auf meinem macbook und
nehme meine videos auf einem imac also
ich würde nicht den knopf drücken weil
ich habe ultra angst vor screen ich weiß
nicht ob es also positiv war das ganze
jetzt zu sagen weil das video hier sehen
ja locker eine halbe million leute ich
würde nicht den knopf drücken und ich
bin ich bin in der minderheit nicht dumm
ich könnte die ganze apple produkte
einfach direkt verkaufen nicht immer
spaß trackpad contractors singer in new
world everybody compared to the likes of
nicki minaj justin bieber way würde ich
definitiv licht rücken es ist wieder da
50 50 situationen also ich will einfach
kein sänger werden oder irgendeinen der
die welt kennt das team findet man dem
motto karabatic manual transmission also
soweit ich das jetzt richtig übersetzen
kann bekomme ich unendlich viel geld um
alles um ein auto zu stecken
andererseits muss es eine automatik
wagen sein da ich eigentlich schalten
viel lieber mag als automatik allerdings
automatik unfassbar entspannt einfach
ist natürlich will ich das machen auch
die leute schreiben einfach dass sie ihr
auto verkaufen würden sowie mit den
apple-produkten ja ständig um hier
bekomme ich auf der einen seite 1500
dollar allerdings bei den nächsten drei
malen wo ich möglichkeit habe sex zu
haben
muss ich nein sagen es ist so schwer ich
wette das ist wieder so eine 50 50 sache
so dass die hälfte sagte ja ich nehme
das geld ich will einfach nur gelten ja
nicht [ __ ] also ich würde sagen aber
naht und ich bin 36 prozent alter seid
ihr alle geld süchtig oder was an dieser
stelle wenn ich jetzt auch das video
meine damen wenn es euch gefallen hat
last auf jeden fall leichter und
schreibt wendy kommentare ähnliche
spiele wie so was also sowas wie mit dem
knopf drücken abbiegen oder sowas wie
was wird öfter gegoogelt was ich ja auch
letztes hochgeladen habe dieses game